abone ol
ve
[Alkış]
o shant
duanı Google
birçok kişi takım
Birçok insana ilham vermiş bir şeyle Siz
konuşturmak istiyorum sağlık sanıyorum
hepimizden daha meşhur onu anlaşılmak
istiyorum
[Alkış]
televizyonculuk alanında on yıl geride
bıraktıktan sonra bulmak zor mutluluk
verici görürüz
bundan birkaç gün önce sevgililer
gününde sevdiğiniz insanlarla sohbet
ederken
konu teles belirler bir planı vardır bir
şeyler düşünüyorum be ama dedin aynı
şeyi anlatma vapurda Çay Simit sohbetin
kamera arkasında Ben 10 yılda çok şey
yaşanmıştır ve bunları birçok farklı
farklı platformda
paylaşmıştır yeni bir şey anlamaz hep
aynı şeyleri anlatıyor dedi ki adama
birkaç onu anlatıyor gelirsin
Ya hayatım oyunlar Bence on binden fazla
soruyu ünlü isimleri sorma şansı buldum
bu sefer soru ondan var gelmişti bir
planı var mı Aslında
fikirde hayatını değiştiriyor ama o
fikirleri plan doğrultusunda gerçekleşir
O yüzden biraz varsa şanslısınız benim
içimde Hayat sloganı pijama sağlık al
sohbetin en çok merak edilen
şehirlerinden bir tanesi
araştırma
Aslında o
[Müzik]
bu çalışmadığı
ve izinsiz Kadın kucaklaşma diyor o
kadar milli arasında 422. programınız
varsa
benim yol gösterici Hayat felsefesini
düşüncelerini senaryolarını aslında
çok önemli
[Müzik]
değil ki o
bu zor soruyordu İnsanların kendisini
düşünmesine ihtiyacı olduğunu
hissettiğim andan beri bu soruları
üzerine gittim Aslında ne hissediyoruz
ne düşünüyoruz
herkesin sağlıklı bir şeyler var Bazen
sakladığımız şeyin ne olduğunu
bilmiyoruz İçinizde olan şeyleri
bilmiyoruz O yüzden en iyi bir şekilde
yaklaşınca da onların hissettiklerini
öğrenmek
sana daha alıyoruz u yine küçük bir
video izlemek istersiniz ve şeylere
bakmak lazım Savaş Özdemir edici görme
konusu ne kadar istekli çok zor sorular
soruyorsun ya
[Müzik]
15 kişi
açık kaldı
hep bir kalp çarpıntısı vardır
kalp çarpıntısı bazen motoru kullanırken
sorular karşısında yaşadılar
geldiğinde sen geldiğinde heyecanlanıyor
Evet heyecanlanıyorum
ama Zaman geçtikçe başka etmeye başladı
senin varlığın bana güç ve
[Müzik]
bu
güçleri ve çok güzel bir şey söylemişsin
sen aldın mı
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
oldu çünkü o insanla tanışıyorsunuz ilk
merhabalaşma anı onu yok olmaya başlama
anı size bir şeyler ifade ediyor bazen 7
sorun ikinci zordu ağzı 15
sorumlu Bazen o
var burada
burada yana sağlık almam gereken bir
bütün soruların cevabını bulmaya
çalışmak kendine izleyenler iyi düşünen
insanların felsefelerini aktarmak O
yüzden plana Sadık kaldım bir on yıl
Geride bıraktığım için
mutluyum
insanlar hisseden varlıklar düşünen
varlıklar bu süreç içerisinde Mehmet Ali
Birand'ın almak isterim Üniversite
döneminde staj yaptığım insanlığı ben
staj yaparken 32 Gün 25 yıllık diyordu
duvara asılmış fotoğraflara bakınca
Allah bir İnşallah benim de uzun uzun
süre İmaj İrem Çünkü maceralı uzadıkça
daha da güzelleşiyor 10'uncu yılı bu
sene kutluyoruz bundan
bu işleri sonra da 47 yaşıma gireceğim
sanıyorum
ve tüm bu süreç içerisinde
Yaşadığım şeyleri daha iyi gözlemlediğim
bir yaş 40'lı yaşlar O yüzden 40'lı
yaşları yaşamanın da heyecan içerisinde
ne de ki Tabii o soru yeni şeyler
anlatacaksın değil mi sorusu aklımda
geceyi güzel geçirdik gün İsmet
İnönü'nün
Karar verme aşamasında
48 saat dur
televizyon yapımcısı sonucu olarak
duygusal bağ
[Müzik]
bu elifler de bir başarıya katkıda
dokunmaya ulaşmış tık bunun neden
hayal ettiğim Hayal ettiğimiz başka bir
şey yapmadım Sorusu vardı tabi siz de
son zamanlarda çok duyuyorsunuz ihracat
ya
Yani önemli bir şeyler
olarak televizyon
televizyon programı yapma
söylüyor ve o
[Müzik]
bu bittikten sonra bize sordukları Şu
soru vardı Kim vardı bulmak istiyor Ben
elimi kaldırdım Evet gerçekten hayal
ettiğimiz bir şey yapmak istiyorum ama
ortada herhangi bir şey yok burada
önerisi
yurtdışında yani içinde herhangi bir şey
getirelim Bu
haliyle yorum Biz aslında buna
Kendinizden bir şey nasıl katacağız çok
basit Yurtdışından getiriyoruz
getirdiğimiz üzerindeki değiştiriyoruz
kendini atıyoruz
bir
şey değil mi
[Müzik]
zty Sağlık Evi her yere koydum koydum
balkona koydum çalışma olabiliyor Salonu
oluyor Bir tane telefonum var bir Oraya
koyuyorum nasıl oluyor buraya koyuyorum
bana nasıl yiyebiliriz artık
olacak gibi değil mi
[Müzik]
o orada mı gördü bir yandan düşünüyorum
çocukluğumdan beri ahşaba olan bir
bilgin var
evin ofisinizi işyerinizi o şekilde
devam ediyoruz güzel olur
arka tarafta bir Usta'nın yaptığı ve
[Müzik]
Bu bir görevlisiyle annesi ile görüştüm
yaşlı kadın herhalde ona yazmış
nerededir bir gece gündüz Akif değil
sonuç olarak bir şey
Yapmadığım şeylerden bir tanesi kendi
fabrika
Çay Simit Ömer
[Müzik]
dahil oldu Başımızdan türlü türlü olay
bütün
bu
tecrübeler bir insana yol gösteriyor Bu
işte tecrübe ediyoruz Daha iyiyiz Ama
bazen de çocukluğumuzda Yaşadığımız
Aslında o zaman ki Sade bizi çocuk
Ömer'i Aslında önünde isminin başına
herhangi bir sıfat yazmayan Ömer dönmek
gerekiyordu
cebimden işte çıktı
küçük bir Lego adam çok çocukluğumdan 12
hala bırakmaktan çok hoşlanıyorum keyif
alıyorum öğreniyorum değişik yeşil neler
oluyor nasıl derseniz Sonuçta
yaparak insan öğrenebiliyor Merve
gördüğümde aklıma bu sevgi gelmişti eğer
biz merdivenin parçalarımı onu bir gibi
birbirine tornavida video olmadan
farklı bir şekilde böyle bir de bunu bir
kutuya koyup bu herşeyi düşüncesi
aslında bana orada işte karşıma çıksın
orada benim o iki ihtiyacımız yurtta
çocukluğundan beri uğraştığım ve oyun ne
dedim Tabi bu fikri kapatma süreci bunu
gerçekleştirme süreci eliniz yolculuk
kadar bildiğim bir şeydi marangoza
kalbim atabilirim deydim burada
sevgilerimi gönderiyorum İnegöl'de Halil
Usta bu projenin çok önemli olan ama
işten çok yoğun Ömercim Biz ve koltuk
sandalye hazır kalıplarımız var onunla
devam ediyoruz Sana başarılar diliyorum
diye nustay olan küçük ses kaydı bu
arada ses kayıtlarını şey çok
zamanlarda da ses kayıtları birçok
belgesel de kullanıyor eski açıdan
bulduğumuz bir ses kaydı
yoğurt 1 bu çevrelerinde peşimi birşey
oldu Onun için geç kaldık kusura bakma
ya Ustacım ben seni çok seviyorum eksik
olma sen yoğun dediği zaman işte
rahatsız Yeter ki ben mutlu oluyorum
Onun Ben de seni çok seviyorum Allah
razı olsun yani Ben de seni çok
seviyorum O tanıştığımız daha çok
sevindim yani
ben de bunları Daha
bir şey yapmadım ki
[Müzik]
Evet şimdi tabii niye isimlerle sohbet
ediyoruz ama hayatın akışı içerisinde
birçok tanımamış kahramanlığı bir ödev
okuldaki çaycı bizim İnegöl'deki Hayır
gibi bir şekilde Ortaokulu bulma süreci
yaşadık Evet hayal ettiğimiz gibi bi
Merdini oluşturması
düşündüğü şey
bir şekilde eve geçersiniz sohbete
insanların anılarına hikayelerine
dokunduk ve bu şekilde insanları bir
araya getirebilecek bir ürün yapma
duygusu açıkçası gece gündüz beni motive
ediyoruz
Aylar Geçti Yıllar geçti ilk iki
düşündüğümüzden bu zamana Üç yıl geçti
hala Ürün tasarımı aşamasının soruyorum
bir şey Satmak da üretmek arasında çok
önemli bir çizgi var üretmekten
tasarlamak dan zevk almaya devam ettiği
süre içerisinde
Aslında böyle niye satamadım satışa
başlamadık gibi bir şey düşünmüyorsunuz
kazanmadığınızı bir şey para harcama
duygusu eğer orada harcadığı şey para
olarak bakarsanız bu İnsana strese sokan
kişi ama verdiğiniz şeyi karşılığında
bir gelişim oluyor bir şeyler daha iyi
gidiyor alabilmek o zaman size iyi
hissettiriyor tabi farklı Ustalar farklı
farklı versiyonlar ya yapınca Bu
olayda çeşitlenme başladı O süreç
içerisinde diyoruz da dedi ki Ömer beydi
tornavida kullanalım bu işin özü budur
Siz Hayal kuruyorsunuz daha sağlıklı
olacak Arkadaşlarından da tamam öyle
yapalım diyenler olunca biz de ödemeyi
nakit yapınca elinizde 3 tane MR denir
ve
ciddi problemler var mı
Evet şimdi Maşallah böyle içinde
Esenyurt
[Müzik]
olması Ağlama
bu günler sağlam
yapacağız Nasıl yapacağız böyle
şimdi o
[Müzik]
bir
toplayın
[Müzik]
Evet şu anda 8 dakikada kurmaya
çalışıyoruz bilginiz olsun bakalım 8
bakıyoruz edeceğiz Arkadaşlar biz tam
yedi buçuk dakikada kurduk onu üstüne
doğru gelir mi
Ne
oldu
Konuşmak istiyorum taşıyorum şu anda
çıkmayalım bir sonrası kardeşim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
uğraşıyoruz e teşekkür ediyorum
başarısızlık hikayesi var
bu
işte bu bir şekilde satmam lazım
O hafta
sakin ya bir belgesel hiç o belgesi
soruyorum benim içimdekileri
yaşanmışlıkları mı o anda o kadar güzel
anlatıyor ki
dünyaca ünlü bir otomobil firmasının
önce Genel Müdürü soru kendi yapıyor
kullandıkları Otomobilde yaptıkları
otomobil Geleceğe Dönüş ve gördüğümüz o
ve iyice
bağlıyorum ağabey
[Müzik]
inanılmaz bir mühendis var John Deere o
irlanda'da finansman bulup
paslanmaz şeyler inanılmaz tasarım
ediyor
insanlarda araba tamamen bitmeden ön
sipariş veriyor ki Merdini Güven herkese
ben buradan istiyorum yanında şu yasıl
Ben beyaz renk istiyorum ben Adres
istiyorum sipariş almış söz O durumdayım
bu belgeseli izledikten sonra ertesi gün
koşarak O çok rahatlamış bir şekilde
arkadaşlar saat
satamayız sonucu olarak sağlam olmayan
bir ürün yapmak 3 sahibini olsa bizi
temsilci Bizim yapmış olduğumuz Evet
hatamız kabul ediyoruz ama ben size bu
süreç benim burada bir konuşma yapmamış
ama insanlarla oluşturduğumuzda ki
burada bir güvenlik unsuru Şu son su
tamamen hayal edilmeyen bir aşağı ilmek
grafiği Bütün herkes siparişimi iptal
oldu
Sonuç olarak ayakta tamamlanma duydum
Çünkü anlam olarak evlilik birlikte
tamamlanmadan uzun bir yolculuğa çıkmak
tamamlanmadan burada olmaz
tamamlanmış duygularını Elinde sonunda
insana daha iyi gelecek buluşlar bizim
işimize bir şeyler tamamlanırsa bu
sonucunda daha iyi olabilmesi ihtimali
daha büyük Biz eğer bir şeyler dengeli
diyorsa hayatın içerisinde o planında
şaşlı olacağı kesin gibi diğer iz
Nitekim merdivenleri hala bekletiyoruz
Onlar bizi dinlerler
yeniden başladık Ceylan Artık iletişim
olmadığı için derdimizi anlattık en
başından hikayene istiyoruz ne olabilir
paylaştık ve bu süreç içerisinde
benim hayal ettiğim şey var
geliştirilebilir bir ürün yapabilmek
Aslında vapurda Çay Simit sohbet de ilk
bölümlerinden bu zamana çok değişir
gelişir ekleriz
üzerine mandalla koyalım İnsanlar
fotoğrafları alsınlar bir şekilde
sağlığı ve solda yazı olsun anılarını
paylaştılar bu renkleri olsun arka
tarafına koyalım neon
bu aktive aydınlatması olsun bunu nasıl
o süreçte hep gelişe geniş şey olur
ve insan içine
tamamlanma duygusu su Bence plana sağlık
kalmadı ki paylaş Vur Çünkü hayatın
içinde
bizim için tamamlanmış olan
şeylere Veya geç olacaktır diye
düşünüyorum Bazal merdiven burada
nereden
alabiliriz onun en son halini de
görmenizi ağzı etti
üzerinde çalışıyoruz Çok güzel olacağına
inanıyorum ince bizim içimize sinsin
istiyoruz Aslında her şey bu kutunun
içinden çıkıyor bu hali
Teşekkür ederim
Hayat bir macera her anın tadını
çıkarmakta gerekiyor Çok teşekkür
ediyorum yine değilsin ki
[Alkış]